And now again, this is Dr. Cutters on section 11 of the book's top fighting cancer in this section
we continue to take into what feeds cancer in dietary issues.
So in previous sections we talked about what is a whole food diet should you be eating a more
eating type diet which is off of meat altogether a more plant-based diet or should you be eating
some meat which we call our covenant diet. In this section we really get into what feeds
cancer as far as glucose and fructose sugars that feed cancer. Better people ask me can I eat
fruit? Can I eat no fruit with this? We'll go back to that whole food section if you're going to
eat fruit you want to eat the whole fruit in organic as possible in your selection as well or juice
grape juice through juice really has zero nutritional value to you and it is just solid sugar.
So anything that breaks down into glucose quickly is not good because that's what cancer feeds on.
So you do not want to be eating a lot of sugar. That's the key component to this within this section
you're going to read on what fuels cancer. So glucose is taken up by the cancer cell
that's how the cancer cell functions metabolically it is able to reproduce so starving the cancer
from sugar is really what you want to do as much as possible. The rest of your body needs sugar glucose
your brain needs glucose as well but you want to get your glucose from sources that break down
slowly. So very important and that's the whole information about juicy versus blended too so if
you're not at a full-gurse in program where you absolutely have to juice vegetables we're talking
to a vegetable juice now that you're making and you have to juice versus blend on a full-gurse in
program because you could not possibly drink all that fiber you're drinking 13 glasses of blended
juice you would blow up after two days but if you're going to only do it once a day then you're
going to juice 20 to 30 ounces of juice a day then blended is probably a better choice that fiber
helps to bind the glucose and it slows the absorption of glucose into your bloodstream so it decreases
the glucose load yet you still get the nutrients so I have a whole presentation on that as well
that's another website or into our back online office so biggest thing with with cancer is your glucose
and then like I said about it genetically modified foods the processed foods foods that are highly
inflammatory etc on the previous sections enjoy this section and we'll see you soon